just have a look at this image for a
second and I want to tell you the story
behind the image okay
this is an image from World War two it's
from the US oz maps a US Army through
the US air force obviously okay and what
it is is a rough representation of some
data some bivariate data you might say
that was collected from the aircraft of
the US Air Force would anyone like to
have a guess what this data represents
Peron what you think bullets is a very
good guess they want to be a little more
specific I don't that's what I see on Oh
forming like when you play okay sure
I'm I'm gonna go with bullets okay now
these are places where there were you
know bullet damage found on aircraft
returning to US Air Force now when
you're designing fighter or bomber
aircraft like they were in the Second
World War you kind of have this tension
between two different things right you
want your aircraft to be armored you
want to protect your aircraft because
then they'll come back right and that's
that's really good but you don't want to
arm too much armor why not
because then you can't fly right you
can't take off you have less range so
you can't go to a further target or
things like that right so you want
enough armor but not too much so they
gathered some data to try and help them
work out well can I put more armor on
some areas and less armor on others now
when you have a look at this I want you
to think about what conclusion the
aircraft designers would have made when
they had a look at all the aircraft and
where they got shot where do you think
they should put the armor so this is
this is what we call the fuselage right
you have the wings you got um your tail
fin back here okay so I heard someone
say put it in the middle
put away the red dots ah that's a really
good yes that's right
does anyone agree put it where the red
dots are hands up i sophie is a descent
APR content a second I want a clearer
show of hands who said put away the red
dot ah yeah okay so I'm getting like
half of you okay I'm Sophie disagrees
why do you disagree if the plane comes
back and it's had some bullets I was
like good on young but majority the
places when I come back because the
pilot just gets shot so like if you're
shooting where the lines aren't where I
like it isn't red then like the planes
missing because it got like we're doing
so well okay let me see if I could
summarize let me see if I can summarize
so so there is suspiciously
there's suspiciously no gunfire recorded
on the cockpit none none on the engines
on this very particularly fragile part
of the aircraft where it's very very
thin why is that you get shot in any of
these places you don't come back to be a
data point does that make sense
right pilot doesn't survive okay now
that's actually exactly the right Roy
did you want to add another way hmm so
placing armor where the dots aren't
actually what these dots suggest is
here's where your aircraft can be shot
and still make it back to base does that
make sense which is kind of
counterintuitive right
[Music]
well okay now actually sir Aang's asked
a really good question and I want to
push on it because that's why this
conclusion is so weird and carrying too
serrated isn't this where planes got
shot and the answer is yes but this
isn't a complete picture is it because
in fact planes get shot all over planes
get shot all over but if you get shot in
these other areas we never get that
information does that make sense so we
have a name for this right we have a
name for this and this is worth jotting
down by the way under the it clicked for
you okay very good
if you want to make a little use me a
little subheading which is called bias
we wouldn't normally think of this as an
issue of bias we normally think our
you're biased towards a kind of person
or a kind of team or whatever right this
particular bias is called survivorship
bias and the story of the person in
World War two who discovered it a guy
named Abraham Wald it's in your booklet
it's there it's just without the picture
just kind of like why would we not
include the picture more feedback for
the next version of this book anyway so
this is not the only form of bias that
sneaks into Dada for example if you do a
survey of people right you don't get
information for everyone you only get
information from the people who fill out
the survey and sometimes that will bias
you towards hearing from particular
kinds of people for example on
restaurant reviews restaurant reviews
right classically you've got humor I
talked about this some this gap in the
data in here this is a classic thing
that you see on restaurant reviews why
do you think that is think about this
well
very good people only right and they're
like I had an amazing experience or I
felt sick it was terrible the service
was awful if you're kind of here in the
middle you just kind of met I that
didn't draw any response from me that
you know pushed me motivated me to spend
time to fill out a survey so we call
this the the voluntary bias right
because it's a volunteer thing you don't
get that all of the information there
there's many different forms of bias you
actually can see a full list there then
we're going to explore a bit later on
but I just wanted you to get a sense of
what this is talking about and what data
is relevant to it okay